this was a big win ladies and gentlemen
rarely is justice served quickly in the
legal system usually you have to wait
years to see result but today
is an exception and i want to share with
you guys because just a week ago we
talked about this youtuber atosi getting
sued for absolutely insane reasons
basically he called out this millionaire
crypto youtuber bitboy crypto and got
sued because of it
what are you doing
what did he say that was so wrong well
he called him a dirtbag and said you
shouldn't listen to him for financial
advice which i agree with apparently
this was so defamatory that bitboy
decided he was going to sue him and
wasn't going to stop until atozi had
paid him for damages and apparently this
lawsuit came while tosi was about to
have a kid and to make matters worse
he's having to make this emergency
response video while his wife is
literally going into labor and they're
running to the emergency room now
i'm not saying bitboy knew about any of
this i'm just saying this to show that a
toesie was in deep deep trouble and this
is why myself and many others made
videos about this topic but honestly
there wasn't a lot we could do until
everything changed because when
winnetosie dropped his response video he
set up a gofundme for his legal defense
which initially raised a few thousand
dollars but then bitboy decided to do
maybe the dumbest thing possible he
decides to mock the fundraiser of the
guy that he's suing uh he says i'm sure
they could all borrow ten dollars from
their mom's purse to help you out there
bud talking of course about otosi's fans
and obviously after that uh things went
crazy because atozy's fans and anyone
watching from the sideline like realized
what this was bitboy was bullying this
guy and then mocking him for it like
suing you and then mocking you about it
and before long and toasty started
bringing in tons of donations from
everywhere even in a hundred thousand
dollar donation from kobe who we've
brought on the show before and within
like 48 hours a tosi raised 200 000
for his lawsuit to defend himself which
suddenly made things a very different
story because it's one thing to sue a
guy when he doesn't have money to fight
you it's a whole other thing to piss off
the entire internet and then try to
fight a case because in my last video i
made it very clear i thought his lawsuit
had zero merit but now it was also
looking like a tosi didn't have zero
dollars anymore and so
bitboy started to backtrack but it's
important to say bitboy didn't give in
quite yet he did double down one time he
said quote you can't literally make up
lies and accusations about people hate
me all you want at the end of the day
people will be held accountable
so it wasn't actually until bit boy's
own like
biggest hero like the guy he looks up to
came to a toesies defense that he
finally buckled and to understand this
one you have to understand that bitboy
is obsessed with a cryptocurrency called
ripple or xrp he calls himself the
commander of their xrp army because
that's my duty as a supreme leader and
commander the xrp army now i have to be
clear no one hates this self-title of
bitboy more than the xrp fans but
basically bitboy makes tons of videos
about xrp's legal cases with the sec so
imagine his surprise when the cto of
ripple comes to a toesies defense david
schwartz says quote please identify one
specific statement that you can prove is
a lie i read your complaint like i did
and couldn't find a single one imagine
finding out your hero is on the side of
the guy you're trying to sue
and he responds you know i cannot make
specific statements until this is over
this wasn't supposed to be you know this
whole nonsense and he says i respect you
and would love to have this convo i mean
just hilarious but david isn't having
any of it and he decides to destroy him
with this so you're comfortable accusing
people of spreading provable lies on
twitter but suddenly uncomfortable when
asked to show one specific instance of a
provable lie i mean guys he's totally
right bitboy keeps saying like oh
there's all these provable lies but you
look at his complaint and there's
nothing concrete so finally i guess
bitboy got the memo and less than 48
hours after all this became public
bitboy decided he was dropping the
lawsuit this wasn't supposed to get this
far
um so at this point like i said there is
nothing really we can do um you know
the money is came in on his side the
lawsuit was never about money um so
hopefully you know it told me now that
we're gonna be officially dropping this
i don't i email my lawyer uh about 15
minutes where we went on air here so
that is gonna be happening now listen
guys when he dropped it at first
i was very excited for a toast to be
honest because here's a guy who was in
trouble
now he's not you know great otozie
announced that he was going to refund
everyone who donated to him which is the
right thing to do it's awesome everybody
sort of wins but then i kind of thought
about it for a second and
i got angry because rewind that clip for
a second and really listen to what bit
boy is saying so at this point like i
said there is nothing really we can do
um you know
the money is came in on his side the
lawsuit was never about money there's
nothing you can do because the money
came in on his side what
what is that about suddenly the guy
you're in a legal battle with has the
funds to fight his case and that makes
your lawsuit worthless do you guys
understand what he's saying there
there's nothing we can do because the
money came in on his side nothing about
the facts of the case have changed here
guys the only thing that's really
changed is everyone found out about it
and atosi got money to actually defend
himself the fact that that is what seems
to have made bit boy drop his case is so
telling for the fact that this was all
about bullying him in the first place
because look i mean what else has
changed i think this was a play by
bitboy who knows he's a millionaire he
knows a toes he's not and he basically
wants to punish him for criticizing him
too heavily and when that backfired i
think he backed out of it and it wasn't
just this statement that bitboy said
when he was basically dropping the
lawsuit that was questionable he also
said this we did not want this to become
public uh i guess when i decided to do
this back in november i want to keep
this behind closed doors i've had
another lawsuit it was behind closed
doors and it worked out great yeah he
wanted to keep it behind closed doors
he's sorry it got out it's already
suspicious when you start to talk like
that but i also don't know if this is
really true because bitboy knew this
thing would become public which is like
what confused me about this whole thing
because way back in december guys of
2021 i knew bitboy was planning to sue a
tozie and i told him that i was going to
make a video about it because i thought
it was frivolous and bullying and i gave
him a media request to respond to here's
the email proving it so this whole thing
of like oh i expected it to be private i
didn't know it would be leaked to the
press that's why i'm suddenly changing
my mind
that's not true bitboy knew for like
seven eight months that this was going
to be covered so it's just funny that
he's like oh i thought this would be
behind closed doors no no you thought
you could get away with it and you
couldn't he thought nobody was going to
come to a tosi's aid he thought that the
only people who would support a toasie
are kids borrowing from their mom's
purse but i just wanted to celebrate
this win and let you guys know that your
direct support just
ends up making a huge difference and it
prevents people from getting legally
bullied because this happens all the
time and it's not always a big youtuber
with millions of subscribers who can
afford to fight it and can draw
attention to it it's oftentimes little
youtubers who don't have a voice um so i
wanted to draw attention to that scummy
behavior and then also celebrate the win
in this case of how we fought back and
we won because it's actions like this
that makes this community so cool to be
a part of enjoy the win for now i'll see
you in the next one